في هذه اللحظات وقبل دخول الهدنه حيز
التنفيذ منذ الصباح الباكر عند السادسه
وخمس دقائق نعم هنالك التزام يبدو واضحا
وبشكل كبير هنا في الشرق العاصمه الخرطوم
وجنوب العاصمه الخرطوم ووسط العاصمه
الخرطوم التي تعاني من سوء الاحوال الجويه
بشكل النوع واضح ولكن هذه الاحوال الجويه
ايضا وما فيها من نسمات للخريف لم تعكر
صفوها كما العاده عدد من الاشتباكات
العسكريه التي كانت تقع في الصباح الباكر
قبل دخول الهدنه حيز التنفيذ كان هنالك
سماعا لدوي انفجارات في عدد من المناطق
خاصه شرق العاصمه الخرطوم ومنطقه شرق
النيل ومناطق مدينه بحري يبدو الوضع الان
هادئا وفيه من الهدوء الحذر الحركه الان
للمواطنين في الشوارع العاصمه الخرطوم
وخاصه في المنطقه الشرقيه تبدو
نوعا ما ولكن باعتبار ان جثه النبض يبدو
واضحا من خلال هكذا هدى والساعات الاولى
الخاصه وانها من خلالها يعرف المواطن اذا
ما كان يمكن الحركه في شوارع العاصمه
الخرطوم جراء الهدن السابقه استفاد من
كثير من الساعات الاولى ومن ثم
اعاده كثير جدا من الاهالي والاسر الى
اهاليهم بعد ان خرجوا لساعات التبضع حتى
لقضاء عدد من الاحتياجات الضروريه يبدو
الوضع هادئا ويبدو ان هناك
هذا بالنسبه نعم تحرك المدنيين هل هناك
التزام من الطرفين بحركه او بحريه دخول
المساعدات
نعم حتى اللحظه لم نشاهد او نرصد دخول
مساعدات انسانيه خاصه هنا في الشرق
العاصمه الخرطوم باعتبار ان عدد من
المنافذ ايضا من هذه المنطقه تكون بشكل
واضح ومن خلالها تدخل عدد من
الشاحنات وعدد من الخطوط التي تربط ما بين
العاصمه الخرطوم وولايه الجزيره شارع
الستين او شارع مدني الذي من خلاله يستقبل
الكثير جدا من العمليات مثلا نستمع لهذه
الرصاصات بين فتره واخرى التي تطلق بشكل
تحذيري لعدد من الارتكازات التفتيش
التابعه لقوات الدعم السريع في عدد من
المناطق المجاوره وهذه الرصاصات بين فتره
واخرى اما عمليات الاشتباك والخروقات بشكل
واضح حتى اللحظه لم نشهدها او نرصدها سهام
طيب الهدنه كمان ركزت على عوده الخدمات
الاساسيه هل بالفعل عادت بعض الخدمات
الاساسيه الى طبيعتها نوعا ما اليوم
نعم سهام هنالك عده مطالبات وعده مناشدات
بضروره توفير بيئه امنه امنه لعمل كثير من
الاطقمه الفنيه خاصه في مجال الكهرباء
والمياه والمراكز الصحيه حتى تستطيع ان
تصلح بعض الاعطاب التي ادت الى تعطيل عدد
كبير من هذه الخدمات فيما يخص الكهرباء
والمياه هي تتذبذب ما بين عوده وانقطاعا
في عدد كبير من احياء العاصمه الخرطوم
هنالك شحا ايضا في عدد من الخدمات
المساعده في مثل هكذا خدمات مثلا كالوقود
والغاز هنالك عده
نقصان في هذه النقطه مستودعات الغاز التي
احترقت قبل عده ايام قبل عده ايام هنا في
جنوب العاصمه الخرطوم ما زالت تحترق حتى
اللحظه باعتبار انها دارت فيها اشتباكات
عسكريه وسقطت فيها عدد من الاشتباكات هذه
الرصاصات ايضا تؤشر مثلا وتع وتعطي مؤشرا
للمواطنين والقاتلين بالمناطق القريبه من
هذا الشارع شارع الستين بالحذر والخوف
وعدم الخروج طالما ان هنالك سماع لاطلاق
رصاص في مثلها كذا اجواء تعكر صف هذا
الهدوء الذي تشهده العاصمه الخرطوم بين
فتره واخرى خاصه وان الخدمات تنقطع منهم
بسبب بسبب مباشر في عدد كبير من الاحيان
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات